jawa is one of china's a-list movie
actresses
at some point she got married to a
developer businessman and the couple
started to make rounds in the investment
world that's why the media adapted her
as china's female warren buffett
but recently people found that xiaowei
was being erased on the chinese internet
china is cracking down on the cultural
world because the party is very much
concerned about some of the influences
over its younger generation
[Music]
she directed a movie called so young in
2013 but now
the movie sentry on the chinese website
equivalent to wikipedia the name of the
director has been replaced by
punctuation marks it now reads dash
and on china's video screaming sites
some of her best movies and tv series
was removed from the sites and on weibo
the micro blog site her fan page
was gone along with millions of
discussions about her past performance
and news
china has always seen culture as part of
the force to enforce the right kind of
thinking the party sees that the culture
scene recently has become messy
especially the so-called fan culture
how celebrities were worshiped
especially online and party sees a few
examples of bad characters
who are sending the wrong message it is
going after
the actors who made a lot of money but
had tax evasion problems one of the
celebrities was removed online because
he was found once visiting a japanese
shrine that has always been a
controversial place
in china
[Music]
so at the same time we're seeing the
parties cracking down on the private
tutoring industry because it sees
children especially those below k-12
being influenced too much outside public
schools
they are also regulating how the kids
are spending time online playing video
games
drawings treatments send a message to
others especially to other celebrities
because even someone like her someone
with her influence
can't avoid being you know erased online
[Music]
and
maybe even more scarier is that you know
no reason was given
the government
sounds vague in what they see as the
correct or the wanted culture
so whether you have a huge influence
doesn't matter they are at the mercy of
the government's policy
[Music]
you